this morning we begin our new four-day
series the world of mothers we are
looking at what it is like to be a
mother across the globe from Europe to
Africa and Asia and we start right here
at home the u.s. is the only developed
country without a national paid paternal
parental leave program
president Trump discussed the importance
of creating such a program for the US
and his State of the Union address I am
also proud to be the first president to
include in my budget a plan for
nationwide paid family leave so that
every new parent has the chance to bond
with their newborn child six states and
Washington DC offers some form of paid
family leave but the majority of
American workers are at the mercy of
their employers Alex Wagner is here with
how much those company policies can vary
Alex good morning good morning bianna
most industrialized countries offer at
least 14 weeks of paid maternity leave
the only national parental leave policy
in the u.s. is the now 26 year old
Family and Medical Leave Act it
guarantees workers job security for up
to 12 weeks of time off but there is no
promise of a paycheck before Finlay
arrived four weeks early via emergency
c-section
Hanna carton did her best to prepare if
you love him the Massachusetts emergency
room nurse and mother of two took on
extra shifts and even cashed out part of
her 401k plan at a penalty to keep her
family afloat during her 12 weeks of
unpaid maternity leave since everything
that has been taught to me no matter
what happens you never touch your
retirement account because that's your
account for later on it's something that
I had to do even that wasn't enough
carden's husband lost his job
her income tax refund was less than
expected and with just five hundred
dollars to spare she must now go back to
work early ten weeks after giving birth
to a premature baby you screamed you say
if you try and get everything lined up
and the best laid plans aren't working
out yeah what's your feeling about that
it's definitely a defeating sort of
feeling
you know I definitely wanted to spend
those extra two weeks recovering being
with my family and getting things in
order across the country in California
and a world away marquita staples Green
is getting ready to welcome her second
baby girl as with her one and a half
year old daughter emerald staples Green
will take 26 weeks of fully paid leave
offered by her employer software firm
Adobe and by the time I went back to
work I was ready I was prepared I had
some time also to think about here are
some of my goals and here's gonna be my
new normal as a working mom I feel
completely grateful but I really wish
that this was the norm only 16% of
Americans have access to pay leave
through their employers which is why so
many women need to secure infant care
within weeks of giving birth
policymakers on both sides of the aisle
are trying to change that there is a
crying need the Democratic sponsored
family and medical insurance Leave Act
would give workers 12 weeks of partially
paid leave funded by a payroll tax I'm
not in favor of mandating this
Republican Senator Marco Rubio is taking
a different approach it's an option that
people can use to sort of draw on their
retirement savings from Social Security
early but it's certainly better than
having to max out your credit cards or
going on public assistance and leaving
work which is what a lot of people
should have to do it sounds like you see
this almost as a sort of emergency
situation and this as an emergency
solution well it's certainly an
emergency situation for someone who
finds themselves six seven eight nine
months pregnant and realizes I'm gonna
have to miss two three four paychecks
there aren't many people America that
can afford to do that economists say pay
leave programs have important economic
benefits like keeping women in the
workforce who then can earn higher wages
down the line and a majority of
Americans do support the idea of paid
leave it's only when costs are
considered whether it's higher taxes or
a decrease in future benefits to pay for
the leave that enthusiasm decreases in
the meantime Hannah carton is doing what
she can to make sure her family thrives
eventually you just kind of have to
continue living with what you have
so if I completely harped on the fact
that there's no mandated maternity leave
and I completely harped on the fact that
you know our finances aren't necessarily
where we wanted them to be and the fact
that I'm going back to work two weeks
early if I really harped on those things
and I could I wouldn't get the things
that I need to get done done right and
getting it done exactly while there is
still deep disagreement of about the
specifics when it comes to pay leave and
how to pay for it the fact that there
and are an historic number of women in
Congress today and a looming battle over
the female vote in 2020 will likely
result in greater attention to issues
like this one and maybe even some
solutions I mean like everything across
this is something that's been happening
women have been having kids forever be
the only ones that can have kids - yeah
yeah and this is something that seems
like we need a solution for specifically
here in this country indeed you're I'm
Alex thank you so much I liked that was
that your babies hitting on your there
was not mine although it was a very cute
and sweet baby I have another baby
coming later oh good thank you Alex and
tomorrow here on CBS this morning we'll
continue our series the world of mothers
we head to Finland which is one of the
best countries in the world to be a mom
we'll show you what that country is
doing to provide resources to parents